- Hi, I'm Rie.
- And I'm Alix.
- Today, we will be challenged
to take a popular food
and make it fancy.
This episode is my first time
to tagging along with a friend
and I chose my BFF.
- Hashtag
- RaLix.
Let's see what we are making fancy today.
- Drum roll, please.
- We don't have a (laughs).
Pizza rolls.
- Wow. Pizza rolls.
Rie, do you like pizza rolls?
- I think I've never had it before.
Let's give a try.
Cheers.
- Cheers.
- It's cute.
- When I was a kid, I used
to eat these like they were,
you know, what do you
eat a lot at like water?
- Popcorn?
(Alix laughing)
It's basically a deconstructed pizza.
- You have that like dough on the outside
enveloping a nice pizza
sauce, some cheese.
- Heavy on the pizza sauce.
- It's very saucey.
- Yeah.
It's a little bit under seasoned.
- This is a kids' food.
- It doesn't have to be.
So many fond memories of you know-
- First date.
This pizza roll gave a little bit TLC
and we are excited to
- [Both] Make it fancy.
- Oh, you got it!
(Alix screaming)
All right. Here's what we got.
Basil.
- Parsley.
- Eggs.
- Burrata.
- Black truffle butter.
- Doppio zero flour.
Extra fine like me.
- Black truffle.
- Whoa!
Pancetta.
- Butter.
- Heavy whipping cream.
- Shallots.
- Semolina flour.
- Why do you say it sounds like sexy?
Chopped Calabrian pepper.
- Garlic.
- Tomato paste.
- And Parmesan.
And from the pantry, we got.
- Garlic powder.
- Salt.
- Black pepper.
- Extra virgin olive oil.
- And vodka.
- Bye.
- Let's get started.
- [Both] Make it fancy.
- By the way, Rie,
I wore my fanciest
velvet pantsuit for you.
- Oh, it's nice.
So first, bake this.
We are not cooking whole way through.
We are just thawing in the oven at 400
and for 10 to 12 minutes.
- Easy enough.
- All right, next step.
- I found some pearls on your set.
- [Rie] Dissect pizza roll.
- And I'm gonna scrape out
the filling into a bowl here.
Did you ever dissect things in school?
- Yes. We did fish.
- Fish.
- Have you?
- Yeah, I dissected (beep).
- What?
(staff laughing)
You are science major.
- Yeah, I was.
We've made it to the last two
and we're gonna save this for later.
- Bake these pizza roll
shells at 400 for 15 minutes
and make it very, very crispy.
- All right. We have our crispy shell.
Not gonna lie, these look kind of good.
- Yeah.
- Should I try?
- [Rie] Is it good?
(Rie laughing)
Put this in a food processor.
- And we go.
(processor whirring)
Guess what song.
(Rie humming)
- "Eyes of Tiger."
- "Eye of the Tiger."
(processor whirring)
Pulsing seems to work better.
- So Terminator?
- Rie, you're good.
- [Rie] Put in a mesh sieve
and make a fine powder.
- And sifty sifty.
We've got our big chunks on
top and a finer powder below.
- We gonna need this fine
powder just two ounces.
- Setting the breadcrumbs aside
and now we're ready to move on.
- I have seven ounce semolina flour,
seven ounce doppio flour.
- Two ounces of our extra
fine pizza roll flour.
- Two teaspoon of salt.
Mix it.
(mixer whirring)
- Make the magic happen.
My mom once broke her
hand in one of these.
She stuck it in and it twisted.
She did it on Christmas Eve
baking a Christmas cake.
She passed out on the floor.
We had to call the ambulance
and we were all in the emergency
room in Christmas onesies.
So I'm gonna put one tablespoon
of water into four eggs.
Give that a little whisk,
pour it in our flour mixture.
(mixer whirring)
Okay.
- [Rie] Take this out and start kneading.
- Rie is someone who loves
to do a lot of things by hand
if you don't know.
- Well, you can basically do
almost everything by hand.
We didn't have anything
when we were cavemen.
- That's true.
- Channeling our ancestor.
- Yeah.
- Dough came together,
it's nice and bouncy.
Wrap this in a plastic.
Rest this for 30 minutes.
- So we've rested the dough
and we have a baking sheet
lined with some semolina flour.
- And we have a pasta attachment.
Cut this in a golf ball size..
Pop in here.
- [Alix] Poop.
(both cheering)
Cute
- [Rie] Teamwork.
- [Both] Teamwork makes the pasta works.
- So we are making a penne,
but it's a little bit bigger
so it's almost look like a rigatoni.
- No. It's a rigatotino.
- We are going to make pasta
with all the dough we have.
- And then we're gonna
move on to the next step.
- [Rie] Two table spoon of butter.
- My favorite food
- Butter?
- Now we're adding the bigger chunks
of our pizza roll shells.
We season this with a
little salt, some pepper.
Oh, for good luck.
- Ah. My eyes!
- A little bit of garlic powder.
We're also adding in some fresh parsley.
This is looking good.
I think we're ready to
move on to the next step.
- Yeah.
- Wow. Look at our pasta.
Our rigatotino.
- So cute. Look at this.
- It's very cute.
I'm definitely this one.
It's a little bent out of shape.
- I like curly one.
I like this one.
- Wow. Look at us.
Put 'em in the tub.
- When you make a pasta from scratch
it feels a little bit softer.
- Softer, yeah.
- But this one-
- It's definitely like a rougher texture.
Fresh pasta actually cooks really fast
so we don't need to
boil this for too long.
All right. Let's give it a little.
(both screeches)
- Are you okay?
- You shouldn't do that.
- Okay.
- Mm-hmm.
- Is it good?
- A little al dente.
Never forget to save your pasta water.
- Looks good. Let's keep it going.
- We're cruisin'.
- [Rie] One tablespoon of olive oil.
- Pancetta.
Crisp it up. Look at the color on that.
- [Rie] Nice. I love bacon
grease and pancetta grease.
- One of my second favorite foods.
- Minced shallot, stir.
What's your favorite pasta shape?
- I really do enjoy rigatoni.
Anything kind of weird like
the trumpets I'm obsessed with.
- I think orecchiette's my favorite.
- I love it.
- Yeah.
Look like a little heart.
The garlic is going in.
- [Alix] Boom.
- [Rie] Chili.
- Calabrian chili.
Look at that color.
- I love it.
Tomato paste.
- It's all starting to really
come together in the pan.
It smells amazing.
You know, you wanna toast
up that tomato paste.
- [Rie] And time for
- Vodka.
So we're doing
- Half a cup. Half a cup.
- two shots of vodka.
(both laughing)
- And we wanna evaporate the alcohol.
- No, we don't want.
- You want a full vodka flavor?
- Yeah, this is college.
Totino's pizza rolls and vodka.
- [Rie] All right. What do you say?
- Yeah, that looks really good.
Mm. Oh.
- Vodka?
- Oh my God.
Okay. Keep burning off the alcohol.
We're doing one cup of pasta water.
The reason you wanna save your pasta water
is the starches in it will
help thicken up your sauce.
And in case you have forgotten,
it is now time for our pizza roll filling.
- Pizza guts.
It has cheese so it'll surely melt.
- [Alix] Ooh, it'd be good.
- [Rie] Yeah.
- Melt that into your
delicious bowl of vodka.
(everyone laughing)
I wonder if those little balls
of cheese like are gonna melt
or if they're like so processed
that they stay that way.
- Guess what the pizza roll mascot.
- Tony.
- Wait, so are we gonna guess a name?
- Yeah.
- What does he look like?
- It's a pizza roll with two eyes
- Pizza roll with two eyes.
- Oh.
His name is
- So does it sound
like a human name?
- Yes.
- Georgino.
(Rie chuckles)
- Georgino?
Manny?
- Tits. Pete.
- And his middle name is?
- Kanye.
- Pete the.
Pete the.
- Last name?
- Totino.
(director laughs)
- Pete the roll.
- Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
(both cheering)
- All right. So it seems like
the cheese is not melting,
so let's blend it.
- Yeah. Good idea.
- Yeah. Just a fair
warning it might splash.
So do you want me to do it?
- You can do the honors.
- Okay. All right.
Oh, it didn't.
- [Alix] Not bad.
- [Rie] Not bad.
I'm gonna add a little bit of pasta water
so it's easy to blend it.
- Good job, Rie.
- Thank you.
- Keep it up.
(Rie giggles)
- Keep giving me a good energy.
- Blend!
- [Rie] Nice and smooth.
- We're adding in our
heavy whipping cream.
- [Rie] Whipping cream, H is silent.
Whoever came up with this tomato
and heavy cream combination, genius.
- Yeah, they should be knighted.
- [Rie] Parmesan cheese.
- [Alix] Add Parmesan cheese.
- Make it rain.
- [Both] Make it rain.
- And now for our little rigatotinos.
There I am.
- Oh. Come on in, Alix
- Jumping in, cannonball.
- Sauce is warm.
- [Alix] We need some
friends in the pool. Boom.
- [Rie] This pool is very crowded.
- And now truffle butter.
That's fancy.
We're really getting fancy here.
- Pasta looks great, but we
have a few more things to do.
- So let get fancy.
(upbeat classical music)
Whew. That was a workout.
Rie, I commend you for your job.
- Thank you.
And what we have?
- We have the Rigatotino ala Vodka.
- And we sprinkled pizza roll breadcrumbs.
- Crispy pancetta, fresh basil.
- Burrata.
- Black pepper.
- Fresh basil.
- I already said that.
(both laughing)
- And
- [Both] Black truffle.
- [Both] We are done.
(soft music)
- Rigatotino ala Vodka.
Very fancy.
All right. We have a special
guest to try our creation.
- [Both] Zoya!
- Do you guys know each other?
- Yeah, I met her once.
Hi, Rie.
- Do you like my necklace?
- Yeah. What is it?
- It's pearls. I'm fancy.
- Okay.
- [Rie] Yeah.
- Do you wanna wear them?
- Oh my gosh. No thank you.
(everyone laughing)
- Have a bite and guess
what we made fancy today.
- That's good.
It's very yum actually.
There's truffle on it
so that is very fancy.
- What are the flavor
elements in the like sauce?
- Pizza.
So tomato, you have cheese.
- Can you guess anything
pizza component, but
- Less fancy than this?
- Like a bagel bite or something?
- Warmer.
- A pizza roll?
- Yeah. Good job.
And it also has about five cups of vodka.
- Oh.
- Did we make pizza roll fancy?
- This is the fanciest
pizza roll I've ever had.
(Rie and Alix cheering)
- Now, we have one last things to do.
Don't make mistake.
Three, two, one.
- [All] Make it fancy.